638 let's switch gears a little bit and
talk football tonight the unlv rebel
football squad back in action they kick
off their season at seven o'clock at a
legion stadium bianca holman is live
outside the stadium with how you can win
at parking and get there in time for
kickoff bianca good morning to you
hey good morning john so since things
have been
full capacity here at the stadium lots
of folks who've come here for the
different events have tried to figure
out the best way to get in and out of
this area as quickly as possible and
matter of fact the university unlv they
actually have a page dedicated to
getting in and out of the stadium
various modes of transportation whether
you plan to drive take the bus whatever
car chair or even take a helicopter so
here's what we learned by visiting their
website on the unlv page so the
university says if you plan to drive
your own car give yourself a lot of
extra time just in case there are any
traffic issues always
ride share or taking a cab or even
public transportation will be an
excellent option
ride share lot it's conveniently located
just north of allegiant stadium and rtc
will actually have a shuttle running
game day just four dollars round trip
those who attended the guns and roses
concert a little while ago say planning
in vance made it a lot easier
we chose our parking facility first
before we came down and pre-paid parked
and it was wonderful everything has been
better than expected that's the best
compliment i can give
you don't want a headache check out that
website also i was on it just earlier
this morning and i was able to see that
the parking passes if you get one
advance for this game it's around 50
dollars also happening later on if
you're planning an advance there's the
byu in arizona on september 4th that's
going to be here and as we mentioned the
las vegas raiders season opener is
september 13th against baltimore also if
you are driving it's important to note
that there's no lining up to enter the
lots prior one hour prior to when the
gates actually open so take note of that
of course you want to get here in
advance but also they don't want you
lining up matter of fact the lot that
we're in of a private business already
has barricades up so again go to the
lots that are designated for parking
also allegion stadium is cashless so
remember to bring your debit or credit
card reporting live from norwegian
stadium bianca holmen 8 news now go
rebels thank you very much you got the
fight song going on in the background go
rebs go they're back in action and of
course we've got the vegas kickoff
coming up this weekend as well
there it is thank you